疑问是父母不同意我们的感情要不要分手？然后，大概是这个情况，我先说一下我自己的情况。我是重点学校本硕博毕业，去年二四年的时候入职在高校教学科研岗。家庭情况是，父母之前是做生意的，后来就是经营不善，在我大学期间破产。这些年，我父母一直就是做一些小本买卖去还债，最近呢，就是也还的差不多了，这是这个家庭情况。然后性格的话，就是因为在我硕士期间，因为家庭的这个变故，所以就是为了咨询一些怎么说呢，就是一个让自己更好是疗愈的方式，所以就会读过一些心理学方面的书，也看过一些研究。所以我对人就是相对来说会比较接纳包容，所以，就是我的朋友们对我的评价都是就温柔且坚定吧，就是我既能够给人一种抱持感，另外一方面呢，原则上的问题也会比较坚持一时的话，怎么说呢，就是可能一直比较受理工科男生喜欢。所以我估计也是后面这两点原因，一个是性格，一个是颜值，就是这个男生也比较喜欢我。接下来我说一下这个男生的情况。这个男生的话，他是普通本科毕业，然后毕业之后就工作了很多年。后来，也就是前两三年的时候，考公务员考到我们这边一个不错的这个体制内的单位，现恰好就是。
他的这个单位跟我的这个科研和事业还是有帮助，就是有关系的嘛。他的家庭呢，呃父母在他出生的时候下岗，所以就是或者呃不是很确定的工作吧。然后他还有个弟弟，他有过一段恋情，当时分手的原因一方面是两方就是他们的性格不合，另外一方面也是怎么说呢，就是当时女方要彩礼的时候，他说，父母已经全款给他买了一套房，那么接下来需要的这个就是彩礼。的话，父母不够的就是他来去添上，大概是这样的一个情况，就是他的情况最开始因为一直没有见我的父母，没有见他的时候，就是我会一直跟我父母说，我还挺喜欢这个男生，接触的也挺好。我俩可能在一起有半年左右了，但是前段时间，就是我父母见了一面。我父母的反应完全不是我想象中那么积极，甚至说他们对这个男生没有说的不好听一点吧，没有任何好的评价。他们会认为这个男生就是在人情往来、人情世故这方面好像不太会，就是感觉这样的话，另外一方面，他的学历跟我相比的话，可能就有点儿差距吧，他们就会觉得未来我会就是在家庭里面，我可能需要牺牲更多。说的再通俗一点吧，可能就是我们的这个收入上都是需要靠我去辛苦的付出。然后对于这个，我本来想跟他们争论的时候，我说。
但是他所在的单位可能对于我的事业还是有帮助的，可能会给我提供一个途径。但是我父母就觉得这样一个不会人情世故的人，怎么可能去给我一些帮助呢？我说，那他如果提供途径，我去往前冲，然后我父母就觉得那你还需要他干什么？我的父母就觉得，包括我自己的这个人员，包括我的亲戚长辈能够提供给我提供的帮助也远大于这个男生。他们就觉得我和这个男生在一起，可能我会吃亏。这是一个另外一个，他们就总担心，因为他们也不熟这个男生的父母，我不知道为什么，他们总是会担心。后面我俩会有就是真的要是结婚，后面会有闹得不可开交的一步，那个时候我就会，我我会受太多的伤了，所以他们就是坚决的不同意。然后，我最开始的时候，我也有点怎么说呢，就是我内心是反对的嘛，因为我有跟我的一个闺蜜以及一个关系挺好的一个兄长去聊，我想分别从男生和女生的角度去看这个事情嘛。他们的反馈，但我觉得出奇的一致，他们就是跟我的父母都是一样的意见，他们是觉得这么多年我这么辛苦，好像不论是我的这个学历，还是说我的经历，还有我的工作，好像更适合再优秀一点的人。但怎么说呢，其实我更喜欢是这个男生的，他一些软性的性质。
也就是比如说，他的性格情绪稳定，他从来不会发脾气，就即使打游戏也不会说是爆粗口。这种另外一方面的话，他也不争不抢，就是很多事情不会很偏执的去固执去纠结一个事情，他总是觉得呃得不到就就算了，就是这样子的性格。但是他们就觉得这种软件的性格，好像对于未来的发展并不是有很好的好处，也就是因为他的不争不抢，可能未来如果我俩的生活质量下降了，他也不会想着去冲到前面，再往就是再努力去争取一些别的东西。我接下来的问题就是两个，第一个是他们就是不论是我父母还是我的朋友们，他们的观点是正确的，所以就是我应该就是分手，还是说我的第二个问题是我这两天确实有思考过，所以我昨天有找他，我就跟他说了这个事情。但是他会对于我的每一个顾虑，他都会有相应的回应。而且，我特别喜欢他的一点是，我是已经30多了嘛，我之前的相亲，我会一开始就说我的家庭条件就是父母有外债，然后现在还没有房子之后买房可能需要我去还房贷，所以可能就是很多人就被就后撤了。但这个男生完全不觉得这是一个事情，所以当我昨天在跟他说的时候，他说这个事情很容易呀，他可以跟我一起去，无论是还父母的外债还是说还房贷，而且他说了还让我挺感动的。事情是他说。
如果没有听到说买房的事情，他曾经有想过，因为他现在的房子在他单位附近嘛。他当时他说他还计划想在我单位附近买房，这样的话，我上班更容易，他也知道我忙，我可能更多的时间会投入事业。我没敢跟他说我父母对他的评价，所以我就很委婉的说，我说我父母特别喜欢你直率的性格，但是，可能你直率的性格更适合和人去交往的时候，是带着带着一种情感，而不是目的和利益的去沟通去交往。可能你这样的性格更适合一个家里没有负担的女孩，你们俩岁月静好的这样子。但是对于我来说，像我这种焦虑的人，我身上背负这么多，我可能需要一个跟我一样焦虑一起往前冲的人，感觉我已经说的，虽然说很委婉，但是可能也表达出我的目的。他总是会说，就是生活中有困难了，也没必要说是就非要往就是向特别好的人看齐。至少我们眼下的生活还是不错。所以就是我感觉好像昨天说完以后，他并没有接收到我想要分手的目的。我就想咨询的第二个问题就是我需要再很明确的告诉他吗？就是我的两个问题。一般情况下啊，就是如果父母家里的所有的长辈都接触过亲人闺蜜都接触过他，都觉得不对劲，这个很重要的信号都觉得不合适。这是一个很重要的。
信就是一个人觉得不合适，两个人觉得不合适，可能还好一点。如果所有人都觉得不合适，这是一个非常重要的信号。在这件事情上，你不要过于自信。因为我以前看过一个很极端的案例，我以前看过那个极端的案例，就是这个女方本身应该是博士，然后她找的这个男朋友呢，是一个硕士男朋友，是单亲妈妈带大的，而且她那个妈妈可能性格比较强势啊什么的啊。当时女方的父母、同事、闺蜜、同学、朋友都不同意，都觉得不能找他。但是女方执意要找，然后他们生活在一起了之后，男方就把他的妈妈接过来一起住。接过来一起住了之后，男方的妈妈是要跟自己的儿子睡一张床的，儿媳妇是要睡客厅的，你知道吗？那到那种情况下了，他这个女方她自己都还没有觉察出来有什么不对劲，还继续就跟他在一起生活。这个案例最后的结果是什么？男方的妈妈趁着有一天这个女孩在家的时候，先是。
到他的脸上，然后让他那个眼睛啊，就是那个近视眼镜啊，就看不见了嘛，看不见就丧失抵抗力，就完全没有抵抗力了。然后就直接三下五除二把这个都下来了。然后男方的妈妈不就坐牢了？男方的妈妈坐牢了之后呢，说她又有什么病啊，有什么绝症啊，年纪又大了什么的，又保外就医啊，什么的那男方的妈妈并没有付出什么惨痛的事代价你知道吧。然后男方还能继承这个女方的财产，就是特别讽刺的是，男方还能承女方的父母给女方买的房产。那个案例你们都看过啊，真实的案例我一点都没有扒瞎。现在男方人家自己还正常的工作正常的生活，男方好像又再婚了，还是干嘛？我为什么给你讲这个案例？因为这个案例就是特别典型的父母、同事、朋友、闺蜜都不同意他嫁，他自己非得嫁。你明白这个意思了吧？如果你这一头父母、亲人、长辈包括你的闺蜜朋友都不同意你非得嫁，那是有问题的啊。这是一方面，另一方面，你要是琢磨明白了，你觉得不合适了，还有一点他说哎呀，给你爸妈还贷款那都不叫事儿，给我感觉有点像什么呢啊，就是在大街上去采访一个大爷，说大爷啊，如果哪哪哪出什么问题的话，你愿意捐100万吗？大爷说我愿意啊，你愿意捐50万吗？大爷说我愿意啊，你愿意把你这个自行车捐了吗？我不愿意啊，因为他没有100万，他没有50万他都愿意。真到他有这辆自行车的时候，他就不愿意了，换到你这个男。
男朋友身上是他现在说的很轻松啊，就我可以跟你一起去还吗？请问他有这个能力吗？他有这个钱吗？他有这个收入吗？他自己的生活顾得过来吗？他如果自己的生活都顾不过来的话，他现在给你不就是画了个饼吗？是不是这意思啊？如果真的是这样，确实我也有考虑过，而且就是我现在能够过得不错，是因为一方面我确实收入还可以，另外一方面也确实是自己一个人不需要考虑家庭，不需要考虑小孩。就是为什么我后来昨天就会跟他说，也是因为我去想到这些现实的事情。但是我感觉我昨天跟他说完以后，好像在他看来这些并不是什么很严重的事情。所以就包括昨天晚上，今天早上他还在给我发信息，当然我也没有。所以我想，那这样的话，我想请教一下王菲姐姐。那这样的话，小毛子还能就是更明确的跟他说出来呢？你就说我爸妈实在不同意，你还是去找更合适的吧。就是你可能能找到更条件更好的。我这情况，我不能拖累你，我这情况负担太重了，我觉得拖累你，我于心何忍呢？是这意思啊，昨天我一直也在说这个事情。一开始可能会委婉，后来我也会很明确的。我说虽然说实话，可能有点夸大了。我说我这个家庭负担太大了，但其实怎么说呢，我父母的外债现在还的也差不多，而且他现在还是有这个挣钱的能力的嘛。但是他总是一直在说他。
那也可以，那这样的话还能怎么说呢？就只是说，只是说我爸妈不同意，谢谢。嗯，好，拜拜，真的，姐妹们啊，我认真跟大家讲一下，如果你谈了一个对象啊，那个所有人都不同意，包括你的闺蜜，包括你的表姐，包括你的父母，包括你的亲戚，哪怕是从小看着你长大的邻居，都发表了一些意见，觉得嗯，不太靠谱。你一定不要盲目自信，一定不要说我众叛亲离了，我就非得跟这个男的过啊，就有的东西，它是互为因果的，互为因果是什么意思啊？我给你们讲讲这个逻辑。举个例子，大家有没有看哪吒那个电影？哪吒那个电影里面有一个角色叫申公豹，你们有印象吗？申公豹这个角色，你说，申公豹这个角色，是因为他本身就心术不正，所以师傅才不看重他，师傅才防着他，师傅才不把好的宝物交给他呢？还是因为师傅防着他，师傅不看重他，师傅把宝物都防着他，他才变成了心术不正的申公豹。这东西互为因果，两种都有可能，对不对？好反过来讲，如果你爸爸妈妈亲戚朋友闺蜜全都讨厌这个人，都不同意这个人，请问他是本身就是一个讨厌的人，还是因为你爸爸妈妈都讨厌他？因为你闺蜜都讨厌他，他最后变成了一个讨厌的人，变成了一个对你不好的人。这玩意儿就是互为因果，但是总之啊，总之当你的爸爸妈妈。
你的闺蜜，你的朋友，所有人都不喜欢她，都觉得她有问题的时候啊，到最后一定互为因果，大概率下到最后就一定有问题。理解龙梅姐讲的这个逻辑吗？有点悬啊，这玩意儿逻辑有点悬，就能听懂的，就听懂的，就懂啊。就如果大家都不喜欢他，他到最后他就会变成申公豹你知道吗，他就会变得心术不正，他就会变成那样理解这个逻辑吗？啊，这玩意儿有点儿悬啊。总之就是所有人，你身边的所有人都不喜欢他。他到最后大概率下就会变成那个心术不正，就会变成那个样子啊。